[Music]
Lord repel this Devil's Powers by the
Incarnation passion resurrection and
Ascension of our Lord Jesus Christ I
command you to depart this child of God
[Music]
foreign
I know it's unusual in this day and age
to devote your life to something
spiritual hey good morning but ever
since my mother's issues I've always
felt a calling to help people
foreign
[Music]
she's not as scary as she looks she can
hear you
you're my favorite person here us girls
we gotta stick together in this place
we have a female student in the class
only as an observer
because as you know women are strictly
forbidden from performing exorcism
female surgeons are once Unthinkable
somebody had to be the first
when you enter the room of the possessed
you are walking onto a Battlefield
strike Terror lured into the Beast now
defiling this innocent child
I can't hear you no
[Music]
barley I'm here
you have a gift I'd like to teach you
this relationship it's personal we all
have a personal relationship with God
and with God
this feeling has followed me my entire
life
you got my invitation
we've been waiting for you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]